c'est la plus grande brocante de france
la 98e foire internationale de chatou
est installé depuis le 15 mars sur l'île
des impressionnistes
chaque année près de trente mille
curieux déambule dans ses allées c'est
une foire qui permet aux visiteurs de
chine et les objets de 1 euro ax on peut
y trouver aussi bien de petits objets
que des antiquités digne de musées parmi
les 500 exposants présents benoît voor
fête cette année sa huitième
participation à cette foire se
passionnés de brocante restaure des
meubles anciens
on a beaucoup de meubles comme ça c'est
les mêmes que l'on trouvait dans les
administrations milieu du xxème siècle
que l'on aime transformer complètement
pour les réadapter que qu'on puisse les
utiliser dans un intérieur beaucoup plus
contemporain
voilà les rendre un peu plus sexy un peu
plus attractif et on les modifie pour
après leur donner une vraie utilité si
vous êtes plutôt bijoux anciens la
spécialiste claudette picard propose
depuis 20 ans sa sélection sur la foire
la brocanteuse coche ce rendez-vous dans
son agenda plusieurs mois al avance à la
une ambiance qu'on trouve nulle part
ailleurs
c'est festif c'est convivial tout le
monde
tout le monde est heureux de participer
je pense à cette foire et les clients
sont ravis de venir passer une journée
quand il fait beau
enfin même quand il pleut pour découvrir
ces trésors sous le soleil ou sous la
pluie vous avez jusqu'à ce dimanche 24
mars la perle rare se trouve peut-être
au détour d'une allée